entsetzen nach morddrohungen die
bundesregierung will hass und hetze im
netz mit allen mitteln verfolgen
investition in die zukunft volkswagen
will das massengeschäft mit e autos
ankurbeln und kommendes jahr 100.000
stück baum und wer kann es beim fc
bayern richten nach dem aus von trainer
kovac beginnt die suche nach dem 9
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zu den heute nachrichten an
meiner seite ist für den sport kristin
otto sehr gern hallo und genannt
bestürzt reagieren politiker quer durch
alle parteien auf die morddrohungen
gegen den grünen abgeordneten cem
özdemir und die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin claudia roth
innenminister seehofer spricht von einer
hoch problematischen verrohung unserer
gesellschaft politisch motivierte
straftaten gegen politiker im
vergangenen jahr gab es nach angaben des
bundeskriminalamts 1256 darunter 43
gewaltdelikte auch der mord am kasseler
regierungspräsidenten walter lübke im
juni nun die morddrohungen gegen cem
özdemir und claudia roth mutmaßlich
verfasst von einer rechts
terroristischen gruppe mit basis in den
usa
florian neu hand mit den einzelheiten
diesmal trifft es zwei grünen politiker
claudia roth und cem özdemir
morddrohungen per e mail
mal wieder man wolle es die mir
gratulieren heißt es darin zynisch sie
haben es nun auf unsere todesliste
geschafft und weiter zurzeit sind wir am
planen wie und wann wir sie hinrichten
werden
mutmaßlicher absender der mails der
deutsche ableger der atomwaffen die
vision einer neo nazi terror truppe aus
den usa die dort für fünf morde
verantwortlich sein soll
die deutsche gruppierung hat das
innenministerium offenbar seit sommer
2008 zehn schon auf dem schirm
also die deutschen sicherheitsbehörden
verfolgen die aktivitäten dieser
sogenannten atomwaffen division sehr
aufmerksam und intensiv die drohungen
lösen heute parteiübergreifend empörung
aus und aufrufe zu handeln
wir brauchen einen klaren konsens dass
wir das ablehnen
das heißt aber auch nicht nur den
polizeilichen schutz von politikern
sondern im vorfeld agieren wir dürfen
diese entwicklung nicht mehr zuschauen
und es ist natürlich jetzt eine
besondere verantwortung auch in den
sozialen netzwerken rechte hetze im netz
vor einer woche hatte die
bundesregierung dazu bereits ein
maßnahmenpaket beschlossen
darin vorgesehen eine meldepflicht für
dienste wie facebook vor allem bei
morddrohungen und volksverhetzung
droh-mails wie im aktuellen fall sind
bereits strafbar
doch auch hier denkt die
justizministerin über eine verschärfung
nach wenn festgestellt wird dass
irgendwo eine lücke besteht und deswegen
nicht verfolgt werden kann dann muss der
rechtsstaat handeln es geht darum dass
menschen mundtot gemacht werden sollen
die sich einsetzen und das werden wir
auf keinen fall zulassen
eine meldepflicht oder höhere strafen
umsetzen ließe sich das nur mit
entsprechend viel personal in der justiz
was die grünen heute erneut fordern wir
müssen zudem eine
schwerpunktstaatsanwaltschaft aufbauen
die zuständig ist vor allen dingen für
hasskriminalität für rechtsextreme hetze
cem özdemir und claudia roth wollen sich
heute nicht äußern
müsste mir postete am wochenende ein
bild auf twitter wir gerade zahlreiche
strafanzeigen wegen beleidigungen
unterschreibe in zwickau hat
bundeskanzlerin merkel den neuen
gedenkort für die opfer der
rechtsextremen terrorzelle nsu besucht
merkel legte eine weiße rose nieder und
gedachte der zehn ermordeten für jeden
wurde ein baum gepflanzt
anfang oktober war hier ein gedenkraum
für das erste ns-opfer enders im zak von
unbekannten abgesägt worden
das nsu trio hatte vor seinem
aufschlägen vor genau acht jahren lange
unerkannt in zwickau gelebt wie wichtig
der widerstand gegen extremismus ist hat
bundespräsident steinmeier betont bei
der einweihung eines denkmals für den
hitler-attentäter georg elser
in dessen heimatort in der nähe von ulm
das grundgesetz kennt das
widerstandsrecht weil es georg elser
kennt sagte steinmeier vor 80 jahren
wollte der schreiner im münchner
bürgerbräukeller hitler töten
er ist als bombe explodierte zu früh er
wurde verhaftet und 1945 im
konzentrationslager dachau ermordet zwei
wichtige termine heute zur
elektromobilität zum einen der
autogipfel gleich im kanzleramt zum
anderen startete in sachsen die erste
große deutsche serien produktion von e
autos
wenn deutschland seine klimaziele
schaffen braucht es bis 2030 7 bis 10
millionen elektroautos allerdings sind
bislang nur rund 220.000 zugelassen
im sächsischen zwickau läutet vw jetzt
in großem stil den systemwechsel ein vom
verbrennungsmotor hin zum elektroantrieb
michael bewerunge so ein
produktionsstart hat immer etwas von
werbe show hängt doch die zukunft von
volkswagen am erfolg des id 3 außerdem
ist vw gezwungen den co2 ausstoß seiner
flotte zu reduzieren und auch die
anwesende kanzlerin will ihre klimaziele
erreichen damit sich mehr menschen die
schönen neuen immobilie leisten können
soll der staatliche zuschuss erhöht
werden
uns ist es wichtig dass sich sehr bald
möglichst viele menschen für die ein
auto unverzichtbar und auch teil ihrer
lebenszeit ist ein elektro auto leisten
können und das elektroauto somit also
wie es früher zunächst der käfer und
dann der golf im wahrsten sinne des
wortes zum volkswagen wird mit dem id 3
und seinem modularen elektro baukasten
hat vw ein alleinstellungsmerkmal auf
der plattform basieren sechs
verschiedene typen des konzerns das
spart kosten im vergleich zur konkurrenz
volkswagen ist sicherlich eine aufholen
und der b3 passiert ja auf den modularen
elektrobau kassen hat sicherlich das
potenzial dass volkswagen in kurzer
frist an eine top position im bereich
elektromobilität kommen kann
in den nächsten drei jahren will vw
weltweit acht fabriken hochziehen und
bis 2025 eine million e-mobile jährlich
herstellen spät dran sei man damit
keineswegs genau zum richtigen zeitpunkt
2020 wird das durchbruch ja für die
elektromobilität seien nicht nur hier in
europa sondern übrigens auch in china
die auslieferung der ersten modelle mit
420 kilometer reichweite beginnt
nächstes jahr dann müssen die
verkaufszahlen zeigen ob der id3
tatsächlich massentauglich ist im
kanzleramt in berlin trifft sich im
moment die bundeskanzlerin mit
ministerpräsidenten und
automobilherstellern um eine der größten
hürden für den kauf von e-autos
anzugehen
die fehlenden ladestationen bis 2030
soll es nach dem willen der regierung
eine million davon geben derzeit sind es
nach schätzungen gerade mal um die
20.000 oder bäcker jeder dritte
neuwagenkäufer überlegt inzwischen sich
ein elektroauto zu legen
viele würden elektrisch fahren können es
aber nicht oft weil alltag und
ladeinfrastruktur nicht zusammenpassen
nicht zuletzt deshalb bieten deutsche
hersteller außer autos nun auch ein
eigenes ladenetz an
ich denke dass die deutsche
automobilindustrie über ihr
gemeinschaftsunternehmen unity stark
aufholt also hier ist man in sehr vielen
projekten für die schnell
ladeinfrastruktur quer durch europa
allerdings ist man hier leider immer
noch etwas hinter dem wettbewerb
der wettbewerb das ist tesla der
amerikanische autobauer hatte vorgemacht
wie es geht und ein eigenes schnelllade
netz aufgebaut um die ladeinfrastruktur
in deutschland zu optimieren fordern
experten schnellere genehmigungen für
ladesäulen eine pflicht für
lademöglichkeiten in neubauten und
finanzielle unterstützung für ladesäulen
in strukturschwachen regionen in baden
württemberg gibt es so ein netz bereits
es heißt safe und wurde heute von
landesregierung und stromversorger
vorgestellt wir sind das erste
bundesland war sozusagen ein
sicherheitsnetz hat also dass nur im
ganzen land im schwarzwald auf der
schwäbischen alb
in ländlichen räumen auch nur 10 km
absolut zuletzt durch sein
außerdem fördert baden württemberg
unternehmen die ladesäulen am
arbeitsplatz anbieten
so können modelle wie der id3 zu
perfekten pendler autos werden
passagiere der lufthansa müssen am
donnerstag und freitag mit streiks
rechnen die gewerkschaft ufo hat die
flugbegleiter zu ganztätigen
arbeitsniederlegungen aufgerufen
betroffen sind demnach alle lufthansa
flüge die in deutschland starten
ufo warf der lufthansa vor nicht über
tarife verhandeln zu wollen
ausland iran verstößt ein weiteres mal
gegen den internationalen vertrag über
sein atomprogramm vizepräsident salehi
bestätigte sein land arbeite nun mit
mehr und schnelleren zentrifugen als im
atom abkommen vereinbart den usa waren
vergangenes jahr einseitig aus dem
vertrag ausgestiegen und hatten iran
wieder mit sanktionen belegt der atom
vertrag soll den bau iranischer
nuklearwaffen verhindern
wir fragen nach bei unserem
korrespondenten jörg brase in teheran
was bezweckt iran mit diesem erneuten
bruch des abkommens
man will dass die us-wirtschaft
sanktionen aufgehoben werden und man
glaubt dass man dieses ziel am besten
dadurch erreichen kann dass man auf
amerikanischen druck mit gegendruck
reagiert auf keine der provokation der
vergangenen monate sei es auf angriffe
auf schiffe im persischen golf auf
arabische ölanlagen oder auf den
abschuss einer us drohne im juni hat
washington mit militärschlägen reagiert
und offensichtlich glaubt man in teheran
dass das auch weiter so bleibt man wolle
ja verhandeln heißt es aber vorher eben
müssten die us wirtschaftssanktionen
aufgehoben werden oder die europäer
müssten die wirtschaftlichen folgen
ausgleichen dann könne man reden
bis dahin aber so scheint es bleibt die
iranische führung bei ihrem strikten
kurs und präsident roh haney hat
angekündigt dass er weitere schritte in
den nächsten tagen bereits verkünden
will
die einschätzung von jörg fauser aus
teheran vielen dank wieder ein urteil in
einem raser prozess wegen mordes muss
der angeklagte nach jugendstrafrecht
sechs jahre und vier monate ins
gefängnis
der 19 jährige ohne führerschein war auf
der flucht vor der polizei mit mehr als
100 kilometern pro stunde raste er auf
einen autobahn-parkplatz bei heppenheim
und fuhr in ein geparktes auto
eine frau starb ihr zehnjähriger sohn
wurde schwer verletzt
in indiens hauptstadt ist der smog so
stark dass die menschen offenbar kaum
mehr atmen können selbst der
regierungschef gibt zu die
luftverschmutzung sei unerträglich
geworden jetzt sollen fahrverbote helfen
seit tagen liegt die 20 millionen
metropole neu delhi unter einer dicken
dunstglocke zu erkennen sogar auf
satellitenbildern hauptursachen
industrie und fahrzeug abgase aber auch
brandrodungen also bauern die ihre
felder nach der ernte abbrennen um sie
auf die neue aussaat vorzubereiten
normen odenthal berichtet delhis
sehenswürdigkeiten sind ja irgendwo
dahinten es ist schwer zu sagen denn
delhis sehenswürdigkeiten sind derzeit
kaum zu sehen
zu dicht der nebel zu stark der smog es
ist die reine qual
indiens hauptstadt die augen brennen der
hals brennt dieser smog tut richtig wie
ich kann kaum atmen und ich mache mir
sorgen
mein herz ist nicht gut und die
belastung wird immer größer die
luftwerte im tiefroten bereich das ende
der skala ist erreicht das ende der
krise nicht sie spritzen wasser um den
dreck zu binden wenn es nur ein bisschen
was bringt wäre es ja schon was
autofahrer landen ungewollt in der
lotterie auf den schildern ist zu lesen
dass heute nur wagen mit geraden nummern
fahren dürfen morgen sind die ungeraden
dran verstöße kosten geld ich bin nicht
aus dede und ich hatte keine ahnung dass
heute plötzlich nur noch gerade die
schilder in die stadt dürfen
ich sah das schild wollte umdrehen aber
da hatten sie mich schon der flugverkehr
wurde ebenfalls eingeschränkt ist ja
auch nicht ungefährlich in dieser suppe
auf den baustellen darf heute nicht
gearbeitet werden all das ein
herumdoktern an den symptomen dagegen
regt sich protest
wir wollen dass endlich was geschieht
das sich wirklich was ändert wir wollen
doch nicht ersticken
die regierung redet viel und tut wenig
das geht doch nicht
verkehr industrie der mensch ist das
problem er könnte also natürlich auch
die lösung sein könnte wenn er denn
wollte
deutschland feiert und das die ganze
woche 30 jahre mauerfall
wir erinnern uns 1989 das jahr der
friedlichen revolution im herbst sammeln
sich tausende ddr flüchtlinge auf dem
gelände der botschaft in prag
sie sind außer sich vor freude als sie
ausreisen dürfen
wir sind das volk rufen ab dem 9 oktober
jeden montag immer mehr demonstranten in
immer mehr ddr städten am vierten
november dann genau vor 30 jahren die
größte freie demonstration in ost berlin
hunderttausende versammeln sich auf dem
alexanderplatz fünf tage später fällt
die mauer aus berlin stefanie dosch
fernsehbilder lassen wollte nacht in
berlin geschichte auferstehen projiziert
am alexanderplatz die größte
nichtstaatliche demonstration der ddr
auftakt zu 30 jahre mauerfall
wir wollen dass es wieder erlebbar ist
was damals stattgefunden hat aber auch
was seitdem sicher entwickelt hat und es
stimmt in diesen 30 jahren war das nicht
immer ein glatter weg aber es ist uns
etwas gelungen dass wir nämlich
zusammenleben ohne mauer in frieden und
freiheit am alexanderplatz protestierten
genau heute vor 30 jahren
hunderttausende gegen gewalt und für
meinungsfreiheit in der ddr organisiert
von künstlern und theaterleuten wir
haben in diesem letzten wochen unsere
sprachlosigkeit überwunden
die meisten redner forderten damals
einen neuen demokratischen sozialismus
in der ddr
wir alle sind hier weil wir hoffnung
haben auf diesem platz ist
hunderttausendfache hoffnung versammelt
die freiheit hinter dem brandenburger
tor schien noch fern bis fünf tage
später alles anders kam aber dass wir
fünf tage später wieder die ganze stadt
gehören würde das habe ich mir nicht
denken können hunderte aktion erzählen
in den nächsten tagen von der
friedlichen revolution am brandenburger
tor wieder ein teppich aus 30.000
zetteln wünsche visionen für ein
friedliches zusammenleben auch in den
nächsten jahrzehnten das thema im sport
das große thema wie geht's weiter
da wird natürlich richtig viel
spekuliert turbulente zeiten beim
rekordmeister knapp zwei wochen vor dem
abschied von präsident uli hoeneß und
der jetzigen englischen woche mit
champions league und bundesliga topspiel
gegen dortmund hansi flick übernimmt
vorerst nach der trennung von niko kovac
von den verantwortlichen heute keine
persönliche stellungnahme das hatte man
gestern abend kurz und knapp erledigt
ausschlaggebend für die entlassung die
zuletzt desolate vorstellung in
frankfurt das wir-gefühl nur noch auf
dem bus existenz ich gebe nie auf und
wird es auch nicht aufgeben
ich weiß es schwierig ist aber
ich habe immer wieder gesagt auch als
ich hier war einfach kann jeder samstag
wollte er noch einen tag später aber war
seine zeit vorbei
ich denke dass dies zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt die richtige entscheidung für
den klub ist die ergebnis sondern auch
die art und weise wie wir zuletzt
gespielt haben haben mich zu diesem
entschluss kommen lassen
seine art das team zu coachen das star
ensemble bei laune zu halten passte
nicht wirklich zusammen
ihm fehlte die unterstützung vor allem
hat er kritik an der form einzelner
spieler
es ist letzten endes so wir sprechen die
sachen an aber die jungs setzen uns im
moment nicht so und das hat nichts mit
taktik zu tun
das 1 5 in frankfurt die höchste
niederlage seit zehn jahren in der
bundesliga anlass für die bayern bosse
den schlussstrich zu ziehen
hansi flick weltmeister als co-trainer
unter jogi löw übernimmt bereitet das
team auf piräus und dann den bvb vor
dass gemeinsam mit hermann gerland ja
schon unter jupp heynckes tätig doch
nicht nur flick ist eine dauerhafte
option auch eric den haag steht hoch im
kurs er aber aktuell noch trainer von
ajax amsterdam spannende tage die da auf
die bayern warten die
formel-1-weltmeisterschaft des vorzeitig
entschieden lewis hamilton verteidigt
seinen titel dafür reicht den ersten
platz zwei hinter teamkollege valtteri
bottas zurück der brite immer näher an
den deutschen rekordchampion ran
es ist der sechste titel für den dritten
eine weltmeisterschaft trend hamilton
jetzt noch vom rekord michael
schumachers das spektakel in
austin/texas früh beendet für sebastian
vettel im ferrari
probleme mit der aufhängung in runde
acht hamilton einmal an der box versucht
den stallgefährten waters mit abbauenden
reifen zu kontrollieren erste attacke
von bottas pariert die zweite dann nicht
mehr totale dominanz der silberpfeile
waters mit dem tagessieg hamilton holt
sich vorzeitig den wm-titel
eine karriere wie ein meisterwerk das
nach hamiltons eigenen worten noch lange
nicht fertig ist das kann ich mir gut
vorstellen noch zwei rennen dieses jahr
spaß haben und gewinnen schön das wetter
weniger schön bleibt grau mit regen aber
mild die details hat gleich katja
horneffer das heute journal um zwanzig
vor elf mit claus kleber hier begrüßte
morgen christ werden sie was wir danken
für ihr interesse und wünschen ihnen
noch in sehr sehr schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
meine damen und herren details geben
sich bei uns die klinke in die hand
mal wird es ein kleines bisschen wärmer
und dann auch gleich wieder ein bisschen
kühler
immer wieder regnet ist zwischendurch
kommt aber auch mal die sonne zum
vorschein wenn es so viele wolken gibt
dann werden die nächte nicht mehr so
kalt so sinken die nachttemperaturen auf
8 grad an der ostseeküste und bis 3 grad
an den alpen und es kommt schon in der
nacht neuer regen heran der zieht hier
vom oberrhein über die mittelgebirge
weiter an die ostsee an der ostsee
allerdings wird der regen gestoppt und
deswegen ziehen die regenwolken morgen
über tag zum teil wieder südwärts am
kräftigsten regnet es also im nördlichen
niedersachsen bremen hamburg
schleswig-holstein und
mecklenburg-vorpommern und auch in
nieder- und den oberbayern fällt regen
in den alpen oberhalb von 1000 metern
auch schnee
es gibt allerdings auch einen
freundlichen streifen ungefähr vom
erzgebirge bis zum oberrhein
da zeigt sich häufiger die sonne bei
südwestwind und da wird es danach am
mildesten mit höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 8 und 13 grad in
norddeutschland und auch im südosten
liegen die temperaturen nur bei 6 bis 10
grad wechselhaft geht es in den nächsten
tagen weiter es wird ein kleines
bisschen kühler schönen abend noch